-Republicans have been
quietly hoping
that Donald Trump
will magically disappear
as he kicks off
a 2024 campaign
that no one except his
hard-core fans seem to want.
And now there's a chance
Republicans will get their wish
as Manhattan prosecutors
present evidence to a grand jury
considering possible
criminal charges against Trump
and the Stormy Daniels
hush-money scandal.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I've got to say,
it's very weird to see
Donald Trump just out there,
campaigning for president,
as if he didn't
orchestrate a coup
to overthrow American democracy.
[ Laughter ]
It's like a burglar
who climbed through a window,
set off the alarms,
scrambled back out,
and said to himself,
"Maybe I'll just go
ring the doorbell.
They probably won't recognize me
if I take the mask off."
He's hoping we all just forget
about his coup attempt.
Like when George tried
to show up to work on Monday
after quitting on Friday.
"The coup?
You guys
thought that was serious?
You just don't know
my sense of humor."
[ Laughter ]
And as crazy
as it may seem,
Trump is already
racking up endorsements
from Republicans
like Ohio Senator J.D. Vance
and South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham,
who explained his decision
to back Trump this way.
-I know the downside of Trump,
but let me tell you
about the upside of Trump.
I am for Trump not because
of the flaws of anybody else.
I'm for Donald Trump 'cause
I know what I'm gonna get.
-Yeah, you know what you're
gonna get with herpes, too,
but I'm not sure
that's a selling point.
Lindsey Graham's
like Forrest Gump
if all he ever did
was sit on that bench.
"My memaw always said life
is like a box of frozen shrimp
you left out in the sun.
You know exactly what you're
gonna get -- food poisoning."
With that said,
Lindsey isn't all wrong
about knowing
what you're gonna get
because Trump is just out there
doing his usual shtick,
flying from state to state,
whining about all the stuff
he usually whines about,
like windmills.
-We demand windmills be built
on our oceans,
our prairies, our mountains
and our plains,
only to realize that
they're killing all our eagles
and our birds.
If you kill a bald eagle,
they put you in jail
for five years.
But the windmills
knock out thousands of them.
Nothing happens.
And it's the most expensive
and least reliable form
of energy on the planet.
And the wind turbines
are all made in China.
Some are made in Germany,
but most of them
are made in China.
-Really trying to recapture
that 2016 magic all over again,
even leaning
into the word "China."
Except his voice is
so much more degraded now.
Used to be up here --
"China!" --
but now he's down here --
"China."
It's more -- it's a growl.
He sounds like a pit bull
who smokes
a pack of Marlboros a day.
"How about this?
How about you fetch?"
[ Laughter ]
"You like the ball so much,
stop chucking it around."
[ Laughter ]
Also, I like how he tells
everyone in the audience,
"If you kill a bald eagle,
you go to jail for five years,"
which definitely means
that after this happened...
...Trump said, "I'm gonna kill
that bald eagle."
[ Laughter ]
And someone told him not to
because he'd go to jail
for five years.
But with a few exceptions,
Republicans are all dreading
another Trump campaign.
That's the central problem
they're facing right now.
They all quietly want
Trump gone,
but nobody wants to be
the one to stop him.
It's like when you leave
a window open
and a bird gets in your house
and your whole family's
hiding behind the furniture
and yelling ideas.
"Throw a blanket on it!"
"Somebody make cat sounds!"
"Put some birdseed
on the windowsill!"
And then your drunk Aunt Vera
just snatches it out of the air
and stuffs it
through the mail slot
without setting down
her Michelob.
But, unfortunately,
the Republicans don't have an
Aunt Vera to get rid of Trump.
So far, the only
other Republican
who seems to be running
for sure is Nikki Haley,
Trump's former U.N. ambassador.
But it's hard for me
to imagine Haley
gaining much traction
in a race against Trump,
given that she devoted herself
fully to the cult of Trumpism
and even pledged to support him
if he ran again in 2024.
And by the way,
she said this in 2021,
after -- after --
the January 6th insurrection.
-He still has
a lot of popularity.
If he runs again in 2024,
will you support him?
-Yes.
-If he decides
that he's going to run,
would that preclude
any sort of run
that you would possibly
make yourself?
-I would not run if
President Trump ran.
-That was in April 2021,
three months
after the insurrection,
and she still said
she would support him.
I mean, what changed?
Were the Trump NFTs
her breaking point?
[ Laughter ]
"I will stand by insurrection
and election tampering
and financial impropriety.
But when an adult man
sells an NFT of himself
as a superhero, I am out."
[ Laughter ]
And can you imagine
what Trump will say about her
if they're ever on
a debate stage together?
"Nikki's very disloyal.
She lied and said
she wouldn't run against me.
That's not nice.
Plus, many people are saying
she strangled a bald eagle."
[ Laughter ]
So Republicans are refusing
to confront Trump head-on,
instead deciding to hope
he magically disappears,
just like they did in 2016.
One Republican
told "The Atlantic" magazine,
"It's like 2016 all over again,
only more fatalistic."
And the writer of that piece
told CNN that Republicans want
Trump gone, but also have
no plan for getting rid of him.
-It was striking
how consistently
I heard, "The party
needs to move on from Trump.
We need to find a way
to get rid of Trump.
We're way better off
without Trump."
But then when I would ask,
"Okay.
What's the plan
for that to happen?"
it would immediately move
into hypotheticals.
Maybe he'll get indicted
and his legal problems
will subsume him.
Maybe he'll get bored
and drop out.
Maybe he'll lose his attention."
Some people, you know,
clung to this long-held delusion
that maybe he would become
a different person
and bow out graciously
and make room
for the next generation
of Republican leaders.
-Who are these people
still clinging to
the fantasy that Trump
will bow out graciously?
He can't even bow normally.
[ Laughter ]
Bow out graciously?
When he lost in 2020,
he sent an army of Oath Keepers
and werewolves
to kill his own vice president.
[ Laughter ]
The only reason
Mike Pence got away
is that he's a fast runner.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And just imagine
how much faster he'd be
if he didn't also clap
while he was running.
[ Laughter ]
Pence looks like
an overeager dad
running to the dance floor
at a wedding.
"I was in the bathroom
when I heard the deejay
introduce 'The Electric Slide.'"
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, if you think
Donald Trump
is going to suddenly change
his personality now,
at the age of 76,
after eight years in politics
and an attempted coup
to stay in power,
you're crazier than those
QAnon people
who think JFK Jr. is gonna
come back from the dead.
It's never going to happen.
If your personality changes
at 76, you don't get credit.
You get put in a home.
[ Laughter ]
I guess the only path that
remains viable for Republicans
hoping Trump
will magically disappear
without having to challenge him
directly is an indictment
because Trump is facing
a growing number of serious
criminal investigations
in a bunch
of different jurisdictions.
There's at least
two grand juries
looking into the coup attempt
and the fake electors scheme.
The Michigan attorney general
is also looking into
the fake electors,
a special counsel's
investigating Trump's refusal
to give back stolen
classified documents,
and a district attorney
in Georgia
has said charges
could be imminent
in the investigation
of Trump's phone call
trying to tamper with
the vote count in the state.
And on top of all that,
prosecutors in Manhattan
are reviving an investigation
into Trump's
secret hush-money payments
to cover up his alleged affairs
during his first campaign.
-A New York prosecutor
is making a big move
that could mean
potential criminal charges
for former president
Donald Trump
just as he ramps up for his
third run for the White House.
The New York Times
says the Manhattan D.A.
started presenting evidence
to a grand jury today
about Donald Trump's role
in paying hush money
to porn star Stormy Daniels
during his first
presidential campaign.
NBC News has confirmed
that the grand jury
has been convened for this.
Former Trump lawyer,
Michael Cohen,
who went to federal prison
for his role
in the hush-money payments,
is now playing witness
in this latest case.
-Wait. They're investigating
the Stormy Daniels case again?
Man, they really are bringing
back storylines from 2016.
If they arrest Trump,
I hope the FBI agent
who puts him in cuffs
rips off his mask and says,
"Hello, Donald, it's me -- Jeb."
[ Laughter ]
"It's too bad you're handcuffed
or I'd tell you to..."
-Please clap.
[ Laughter ]
"Did somebody say,
'Please clap'?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, you know, I think that's
the last time
we're gonna use the clip of
Mike Pence running and clapping.
Unless would it be fun
to see what it would look like
if the tarmac lights
were hooked up to a clapper?
[ Laughter ]
I think it was -- I think it was
a little bit of fun.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you might be asking,
"Why are Manhattan prosecutors
diving back into the
Stormy Daniels case now?"
Well, for one thing,
it was always very weird
that the only guy
who did any jail time
was Trump's ex fixer,
Michael Cohen,
even though it was Trump himself
who orchestrated the scheme
and even signed the check.
They literally
have his signature
on a hush-money payment
for which one of his underlings
went to jail.
The only way it could have been
more damning is if,
in the memo, Trump wrote
"For hush money
plus killing that bald eagle."
[ Laughter ]
And yet Trump wasn't charged.
In fact, it seems like part
of the reason prosecutors
are reopening the case
is that they came very close
to charging him the first time.
CNN reported that prosecutors
had actually weighed
whether to bring a case
against Trump
near the end of his presidency,
but decided that the
other investigations of Trump
were probably more important.
So, basically,
Trump got away with one crime
by committing other
even worse crimes.
It's a classic legal strategy.
People don't know this,
but the Son of Sam
only went on that killing spree
so he wouldn't go to jail
for shoplifting.
[ Laughter ]
Shoplifting his dog
also told him to do.
"Take the Twizzlers,
but don't pay for them."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, who knew there was
this giant loophole in the law
where you could get away
with one crime
by committing
an even worse crime?
Are there commercials about this
that I haven't seen?
Are you worried about
a parking fine?
Are you under investigation
for petty theft?
Did you get caught shoplifting?
Why not call Meyers & Meyers
right now?
We'll help you stay out of jail
by doing something way worse.
Bank robbery, arson,
even murder -- we'll help you
commit a much more
heinous crime
so prosecutors will let you off
on your smaller crimes.
The only thing we don't do
is dognapping!
Stop calling us and asking us
if we do dognapping.
We will not help
lure your neighbor's dog
into a burlap sack
using sausage-flavored treats.
Stop asking us to do that!
We don't do that!
Anyway,
if you need help, call now.
Meyers & Meyers,
personal attorneys.
We'll help you beat the rap
by doing even worse crap.
Except for dognapping!
And we also won't...
Kill a bald eagle.
[ Laughter ]
This has been...
"A Closer Look"!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]